i do feel like this new future album
kind because i feel like future
i don't know his projects were kind of
missing
for me the last like i don't know i
would say like six years worth of
projects just ain't hit like i'm a
future fan and it hit like 56 nights and
right [ __ ] right and so this is me and
metro wasn't physically there so now
it's different yeah and uh i just saw
a tweet go viral
um that said we're not gonna act like
future's album isn't better than
kendrick's up
i i agree see look you know what this
album crazy future just finished this
album at the studio with me and metro
like the whole time every day with us in
there you guys were physically together
with him three months he just was all in
the same building and that's what
matters like i can't take his credit in
the room what he did like what songs he
picked
on his own
or whatever he did but we were
definitely all in the same exact
building like that makes a difference
with him he gets a vibe off of like if i
just walk in the room like i walk in the
room chained on richard miller yeah
so you guys uh
well first of all what are your thoughts
on the kendrick album
i only heard two songs i know i haven't
listened oh i'm only heard the one with
the video with the
with the face [ __ ] everybody faces
switch yeah uh yeah i like that and i
heard the other [ __ ] when he was on the
roof
when he was doing the burpees the n95
yeah yeah the black and white video yeah
yeah number one so i heard i like
kendrick though
yeah you know kendrick's amazing i love
kendrick um i love both the albums yeah
it's okay to like both things you know
yeah yeah for sure i i'm not gonna sit
here and like i don't know but you
haven't listened to the kendrick album
nah but but you do have four beats on
the future album yeah yeah do you and
future ever trade like uh baby mama like
uh tactics
because he i feel like he's the king of
baby mamas he's kind of like that dude
uh what's his name uh you know rodgers
kramarti in the nfl who's got like 21
kids you know how braz brett kind of
like
he kind of like like [ __ ] on the
internet like when i go to the studio
like i could be having the worst day on
the internet
yeah
he just will not talk about that
like we'll do talk we'll do everything
else it's like that's one thing we do
with each other like we know if even if
i'm getting drug on the internet they're
like ah this person with this person ah
look at you
we just that [ __ ] ain't even happening
when we're in the studio that's one
thing i can say almost like a nice
disconnect yeah he just he disconnected
from that [ __ ] like completely like he
already he see it but he just already